M's got a funny story he's telling me
the other this was yesterday he's
telling me every time A's outside this
kid Drives By I'm driving he's out
walking oh he's out walking okay or on
the school bus every time he sees M he
flips him the bird like the [__] you
finger there are certain guys like
adults who kids just want to goof on
yeah I guess mamed has one of those
faces you know what I mean or something
around most adults you're usually a
little nervous this kid's so not nervous
around met always flips him the bird
like he's like [__] you I said my well
oh you know so what he goes yeah don't
worry I I went and told his parents oh
god well I I wrote a note and I put it
in their parents mailbox what did you
write in the note I just said hey you
know I I I want you to know that your
son has uh been flipping me off when I'm
driving through the
neighborhood what a note to write so
what did they do did they write you back
I I haven't heard from them all they
should write you back and go [__] you
you know it's a the kid's a little [__]
it's a big giant house he's like a rich
spoiled kid I'm sure what's his beef
with you I have no idea literally I was
said anything to him just driving behind
a school bus one day and the kid turns
around and just starts giving me the
bird I think he was trying to impress
his friends or something and then yeah
got off the bus and was flipping me off
but I'm with my family so I'm like I
have to do something care who cares I
wouldn't care so if you're with and your
kids and someone's flipping you off yeah
it's like look at this douche he's
flipping me off what are you you wrote a
letter to his parents not a letter it's
a note I say it makes you look like a
douche writing his parents like you
can't like handle it well yeah that I
was like should I get out of my car and
confront the kid then it's like what if
I get my ass kicked by a high schooler
yeah he's going to kick your ass he
looked like he probably could yeah he's
probably like a cool kid football yeah
now I was a little [__] like that in
high school I someone should have told
my parents what I was up to I would be
in better shape I don't know writing a
letter is a real [__] move oh stop it
it's like I'm telling you you're not
going up to confront anyone no why I'm
not over them flipping me the bird so
you flipping and he's not going to write
a letter H he'd have someone write a
letter for him no I
wouldn't can I tell you why this kid's
flipping you off and don't take it the
wrong way yeah okay you know when you
wear like cowboy boots on that cowboy
hat mhm kids think you're a douche when
you dress like that you know what I mean
it's he goes around outside like that
yeah I'm telling you man you're like a
walking poster for some kid to flip the
bird you know just dress normal okay I I
get complimented on the hat everywhere I
go but yeah you know what don't wear
anything are talking about the Hat
exactly don't wear anything that's going
to get you compliments or people are
talking about try to blend in in your
neighborhood you walking around like a
sombrero and a cowboy boots no the boots
are Co
off like if I was a kid I'd be like hey
[__] that guy he's like Indiana jerk
off you know I'd flip you the
bird